[Musik]
wart ihr in letzter Zeit mal im Kino
dann habt ihr euch dort mit hoher
Wahrscheinlichkeit auch einen Film
angesehen der eine geopolitisch
hochgradig brisante Angelegenheit
thematisiert und dadurch international
die Gemüter in Wallung bringt und nein
ich meine damit nicht das Atombomben bei
Oppenheimer sondern diesen hier
[Musik]
Barbie movie in Vietnam verboten wegen
Karte des Südchinesischen Meeres vietnam
hat den kommenden Barbie Film wegen
einer Szene verboten die eine Karte
zeigt auf der umstrittene chinesische
Gebietsansprüche in Südchinesischen Meer
verzeichnet sind Vietnam gehört zu einer
Reihe von Ländern die Chinas Anspruch
auf fast das gesamte Süd chinesischer
Meer anfechten Peking war seit Jahren
Militärstützpunkte auf künstlichen
Inseln in dem Gebiet und führt dort auch
häufig Marine Patrouille durch um seine
Gebietsansprüche gelten zu machen oha
wer hätte das gedacht Barbie die
geopolitische provokateurin aber wieso
eigentlich liegen die Nerven in Hanau
derart blank das Vietnam den Barbie Film
noch vor seiner Veröffentlichung
verboten hat nun in der Tat geht es um
eine verdammt ernste Angelegenheit eine
Frage von Krieg und Frieden falls ihr
nämlich glaubt dass Russland Invasion
der Ukraine der einzige große Krieg in
diesen jahrzehn sein wird können wir
alle nur hoffen dass ihr Recht behalten
werdet aber um eine solche Vorhersage
mit Sicherheit treffen zu können müssten
wir genau wissen wie sich China
verhalten Handwerks ihr wisst ja bereits
dass dieses Land schon seit einiger Zeit
damit droht in Taiwan einzumarschieren
und ich bin mir sicher dass viele von
euch denken dass die Insel Formosa
früher oder später die nächste Ukraine
werden wird aber was wäre wenn ich euch
sagen würde dass es Leute gibt die
glauben dass die asiatische Ukraine
letztendlich Vietnam und nicht Taiwan
sein könnte und glaubt nicht dass es
hier um reine Spekulation handelt es
gibt viele Argumente die dafür sprechen
dass eine reales Risiko besteht die
Spannungen zwischen China Vietnam und in
Philippinen wegen umstrittene Inseln
nehmen zu tatsächlich hat China sogar
vietnamesische Fischerboote im
Südchinesischen Meer versenkt aber sein
wir ehrlich für Vietnam ist das nichts
Neues schließlich befanden sich die
beiden Länder historisch schon häufiger
miteinander im Krieg die Geschichte der
beiden Länder geht viele Jahrhunderte
zurück und sie ist im großen und ganzen
nicht von Frieden und Vertrauen geprägt
offener Krieg zwischen China und Vietnam
herrschte zuletzt 1979 kurz nach dem
Ende des berühmten Bürgerkriegs in den
die USA militärisch angegriffen hatten
aber Moment mal werdet ihr sagen sind
das nicht beides kommunistische Regimes
hat der Internationale Sozialismus als
gemeinsame Ideologie sie nicht vereint
naja beide Regimes waren und sind nach
eigener Aussage nach wie vor überzeugte
Kommunisten aber wenn es um Machtkämpfe
geht kann die Ideologie schon mal in den
Hintergrund treten es sollte daher nicht
überraschen das Vietnam versucht sich so
gut wie möglich zu stärken um eine
weitere chinesische Invasion zu
verhindern und was soll ich sagen die
Geschichte lehrt uns nun mal dass dies
die klügste Strategie ist die das Land
verfolgen kann wie wir sehen werden ist
dies auch für die USA von großen
Interesse die USA wollen die chinesische
Explosion im südchinesischen mehr
eindämmen ein Ziel das Vietnam als
Anrainer anders mehr aus vollem Herzen
teilt und ausgerechnet Vietnam man
könnte bei diesem Projekt eine
Schlüsselrolle spielen
mit fast 100 Millionen Einwohnern und
einem beeindruckenden
Wirtschaftswachstum in den letzten
Jahren entwickelt sich Vietnam zunehmen
zu einem weiteren regionalen gegen
Gewicht zu China ja genau zu noch einem
Gegengewicht zu China ihr wisst schon
neben Japan Südkorea Singapur Taiwan den
Philippinen und noch vielen anderen
Ländern in der Region möglicherweise
sogar Indien wenn man die in der noch
zur Region hinzuzählen möchte
chiasposition ist also überhaupt nicht
so stark wie es auf den ersten Blick
erscheinen mag
[Musik]
gibt insbesondere auf der Suche nach
Bündnispartnern hat sich China als er
erfolglos erwiesen wir dürfen aber nicht
vergessen dass obwohl Vietnam zwar
keinen Freund Chinas ist es denn noch
eine kommunistische Diktatur bleibt und
Bündnisse mit autoritären Regimes zu
einer Menge Probleme führen können ich
meine seht euch nur die nato-situation
mit der Türkei an aber darüber werden
wir in einem anderen Video sprechen also
bitte Abo und Glöckchen nicht vergessen
um es nicht zu verpassen ach ja und wenn
ihr unsere Arbeit unterstützen möchtet
könnt ihr das über den Spenden Link tun
den ich euch in die Videobeschreibung
packt habe allen bisherigen wie
zukünftigen Spendern möchten wir dafür
herzlich danken und wenn ihr das
erledigt habt stellen sich ein paar
Fragen kann der Westen Vietnam wirklich
vertrauen inwieweit könnte das Land ein
verlässlicher militärischer Partner für
die USA werden und könnten die
Spannungen zwischen Vietnam und China zu
einem neuen Krieg eskalieren heute
werden wir all diese spannenden Fragen
natürlich beantworten und zwar wieso oft
in dem wir zuerst einen kurzen Blick in
die Geschichte werfen
[Musik]
der Kreuzweg des asiatischen Kommunismus
wenn wir uns die Geschichte und die
interne Organisation Chinas und Vietnams
anschauen erkennen wir auf den ersten
Blick dass sie im Grunde genommen eine
parallele Entwicklungsgeschichte
durchlaufen haben die aktuellen Regimes
beide Länder kamen durch sozialistische
Revolution an die Macht in beiden wurden
kommunistischen Diktaturen errichtet die
heute noch Bestand haben und beide
begann nach einiger Zeit ihre Wirtschaft
zu reformieren um sich für den
internationalen Markt zu öffnen Vietnam
begann seine wirtschaftsreformin schon
1986 mit dolmoi zu deutsch Erneuerung
dies geschah also 8 Jahre nachdem sie
Wirtschaftsreformen in China eingeleitet
worden tatsache ist dass beide Länder
begannen das privat Eigentum an
landwirtschaftlichen Gütern im
Besonderen und an der übrigen Wirtschaft
im Allgemeinen zu fördern außer die
vereinfachten sie ausländische
Investitionen und intensivierten ihre
Handelsbeziehungen mit den Rest der Welt
dank dieser Veränderungen ernteten sie
innerhalb weniger Jahrzehnte saftige
Erträge wie ihr sehen könnt begannen
beide Volkswirtschaften zu florieren
in dieser Grafik könnt ihr klar erkennen
wie sich China dass seine Reformen fast
ein jahrzehn früher begonnen hat von
Vietnam abgesetzt hat insbesondere als
es zu Beginn des 21 jahrhunderts der
Welthandelsorganisation beitragen
dennoch haben beide Länder insgesamt
eine mehr als bemerkenswerte Entwicklung
durchlaufen in nur 30 Jahren hat Vietnam
den realen Wert seine Produktion um das
12-fache gesteigert werden China den
Wert seine Produktion umfasst das
20-fache erhöhen konnte und die Wahrheit
ist das für über zwei Länder mit vielen
Gemeinsamkeiten sprechen die aber
gleichzeitig auch viele Unterschiede
aufweisen im Falle Vietnams kam die
Welle der Wirtschaftsreformen nicht nur
fast ein Jahrzehnt später sondern man
muss auch bedenken dass das Land als es
endlich soweit war gerade zwei Kriege
hinter sich hatte zuerst einen blutigen
Bürgerkrieg inklusive Intervention der
USA und danach einen Krieg gegen China
ganz genau Vietnam war um den
Jahreswechsel
1978/79 im von China gestürzten
Kambodscha einmarschiert um den dortigen
Diktator Paul Pott der an der Spitze der
Erfolg mehr gerade einen der blutigsten
Völkermorde der Geschichte verübt hatte
Einhalt zu gebieten ganz genau selbst
die Kommunisten in einer neue konnten
die Massaker dieses terror-regimes
einfach nicht mehr mit ansehen und
entschieden sich ihren Nachbarvolk zu
befreien und zwar trotzdem das Peking
seine Hand fest über die schlechte der
killing viel hielt und was passierte
dann als Unterstützer des
kambodschanischen Regimes marschierten
die Chinesen daraufhin in den Norden
wird namens ein wo sie sich zum Glück
jedoch in einem nicht einmal einen
ganzen Monat ohne Krieg sagen wir mal
eine blutige Nase geholt haben na
erinnert einen das nicht irgendwie an
die aktuelle Situation Russlands gegen
die Ukraine auf jeden Fall wurde damals
aber einen Status Quo Frieden
geschlossen so dass ich beide Seiten
irgendwie zum Sieger erklären konnten
trotzdem die unsägliche historische
Rolle Chinas gegenüber seinen Nachbarn
ist ein Thema für ein oder sogar mehrere
eigene Videos also Abo nicht vergessen
falls es euch auch interessiert generell
können wir sagen dass Vietnam seine
Reformen bereits in Angriff genommen hat
als ist er war und noch mehr Probleme
aller Art hatte als China und dieser
Unterschied erklärt zum Teil auch die
aktuelle Kluft natürlich gehen die
heutigen Differenzen über den reinen
wirtschaftlichen Bereich hinaus China
zwischen kollektiver macht und dem
Personenkult von skijimping ganz genau
während in den letzten Jahren mit Shisha
Ping in China Totalitarismus und ein auf
die Spitze getriebener Personenkult
wieder an Stärke gewonnen haben sieht es
in Vietnam anders aus und das beweisen
Nachrichten wie diese Vietnam
Präsidenten New England tritt inmitten
der korruptionsbekämpfungskampagne der
Kommunistischen Partei zurück in China
ist der Generalsekretär der
Kommunistischen Partei seit 1989 auch
der Präsident des Landes in Vietnam
hingegen scheint so was heute und
denkbar zu sein
[Musik]
tatsächlich beruht die kommunistische
Diktatur in Vietnam auf vier Säulen dem
Generalsekretariat den Premierminister
dem Präsidenten und dem Vorsitzenden der
Nationalversammlung und seitdem toto
schimans im Jahr 1969 wird jedes dieser
Ämter von verschiedenen
personenbekleidet die gewissermaßen als
Gegengewicht zueinander fungieren die
vietnamische Nationalversammlung die
natürlich nicht demokratisch ist weist
aber zumindest eine gewisse Aktivität
auf sie kann sogar ein Veto gegen
Regierungsbeschlüsse einlegen und falls
notwendig misstrauensanträge gegen den
Premierminister Stellen bisher haben
diese Mechanismen den vietnamesischen
Staatsapparat eine gewisse sowohl
funktionale als auch temporale
Gewaltenteilung verliehen was das Regime
ausgewogene Frische und freier machte in
China wurde die Macht nie der hat
aufgeteilt doch immerhin wechselten sich
der Führer und die politische Eliten
mehrfach ab mit der Konsolidierung der
matschigem Dings ist das jedoch auch
verschwunden und was bedeutet das alles
tun im Grunde kann in Vietnam niemand so
plötzlich und eigenmächtig den Kuss
wechseln die China und es bedeutet eben
meinen auch weniger Einschränkungen für
die Bevölkerung während beispielsweise
in China Facebook und Youtube komplett
geblockt sind gibt es in Vietnam freien
Zugang selbst so Videos die die
Kommunistische Partei kritisieren wenn
auch mit einigen Einschränkungen soweit
so gut aber abgesehen von den
innenpolitischen Verhältnissen sind die
größten Differenzen zwischen den beiden
Ländern vor allem in ihrer Politik in
Südchinesischen Meer zu finden obwohl
sie auch dort quasi eine wichtige
Gemeinsamkeit haben beide Länder
beanspruchen ja weitgehend dieselben
Gebiete und überlappende
Gebietsansprüche bedeuten nicht nur das
Barbie Filme verboten werden sondern vor
allem das Spannungen zwischen den
Ländern jederzeit Aufnahmen könnten und
sich bei einer unkontrollierten
Eskalation die Geschichte vielleicht
wiederholen könnte wie gesagt die beiden
Länder befanden sich schon einmal im
Krieg und 1979 ist immerhin erst 40
Jahre her so manchen Vietnamesen ist die
chinesische Aggression noch in bester
Erinnerung auf der anderen Seite nutzt
das Regime in Peking immer mehr Tasten
auf seiner nationalistisch
militaristischen Klaviatur wie in ganzen
Land wird die Bevölkerung schon seit
Jahren auf nationalistische Großmacht
Fantasien konditioniert und darauf dass
Krieg ein probates Mittel darstellt um
diese umzusetzen und wir alle wissen ja
wohin diese gezielte Propaganda im Falle
Russlands geführt hat dasselbe Risiko
ist also auch in China durchaus real es
zu unterschätzen wer ein großer Fehler
für jeden Nachbarn die Frage lautet
daher wie oft Vietnam zu verhindern dass
die Spannungen mit seinem nördlichen
Nachbarn wieder aufflammen und wie will
sich das Land verteidigen falls es doch
noch dazu kommen sollte genau das werden
wir jetzt unter die Lupe nehmen
der liebesgröße aus Moskau
[Musik]
bevor wir fortfahren würde ich euch noch
gerne darauf aufmerksam machen das wäre
endlich eine discord Server für euch
unsere Community erstellt haben dort
könnt ihr euch nicht nur gegenseitig
viel näher kennenlernen und austauschen
sondern uns zum Beispiel auch Material
für unsere Videos geben daneben gibt es
dort auch die Möglichkeit sich unsere
Videos vorab anzusehen und uns vor ihrer
Veröffentlichung auf etwaige Fehler
hinzuweisen wir hoffen auf diese Weise
mit eurer Hilfe ein noch höhere Qualität
erreichen zu können also kommt jetzt
gleich auf unsere neuen discord Server
den Link dazu findet ihr in der
Beschreibung unter diesem Video diesmal
wirklich das letzte Mal habe ich das
nämlich vergessen so und nun zurück nach
Vietnam es ist unvermeidlich dass wir
jedes Mal wenn wir hier im Westen den
Namen Vietnam hören sofort an den
Vietnamkrieg denken über den Dutzende
von Film gedreht worden und dann die die
Vereinigten Staaten mit 10.000 von
Soldaten beteiligt waren um den Süden
des Landes gegen den kommunistischen
Norden zu unterstützen um euch eine
Vorstellung davon zu geben 1968 hatte
die nordamerikanische macht fast 600.000
Soldaten in Südvietnam stationiert
insgesamt waren die USA fünf Jahre lang
an diesen Krieg beteiligt doch von der
im erwähnten chinesischen Invasion
Vietnams 1979 hatten die meisten von
euch wahrscheinlich noch nichts gehört
dennoch auf den ersten Blick scheint
Vietnam auch heute noch enorm verwundbar
gegenüber Aggression seines nördlichen
Nachbarn zu sein schaut euch nur mal
diese Karte an
wenn ihr genau hinseht erkennt ihr das
Vietnam geographisch gesehen China
völlig ausgeliefert ist entweder an der
Grenze im Norden wo die Chinesen 79
einmarschiert sind oder an der Küste wo
es nicht nur praktisch umzingelt ist
sondern auch mit der größten Marine der
Welt nach der Zahl der Schiffe
konfrontiert ist und vergessen wenn ich
das im Südwesten vietnames Kambodscha
liegt damals wie heute ein von China
weitgehend abhängiger Staat und dann
gibt es doch Laos dass die Seiten
wechseln könnte wenn sich einen meist
bietender findet es überrascht also
nicht dass ich Angesicht eines solchen
Szenarios die ernste Frage stellt ob
Vietnam einen eindeutig wirklich
unabhängigen Diskurs führen kann ob das
Land eine eigenständige Außenpolitik
überhaupt riskieren kann und das ist im
Grunde die Ursache dafür warum Vietnam
in den letzten Jahren sowohl militärisch
als auch wirtschaftlich immer näher an
Länder wie Japan und Indien herangehen
ist nämlich um Partner als Gegengewicht
zum großen Nachbarn zu finden aber sein
wenn man ehrlich die Freundschaft
zwischen diesen Ländern ist eher
oberflächlicher Natur wenn wir wirklich
herausfinden wollen wäre der beste
Freund wird Namens ist müssen wir uns
ein Land ansehen das im letzten Jahr
nicht gerade positiv aufgefallen ist
genau wir sprechen über Russland
schon seit der hoi Minh era ist moskauz
Einfluss im Land unendlich viel größer
als der Pickings in gewisser Weise hat
das damit zu tun dass die Wurzeln des
kommunistischen Denkens in Vietnam
direkt aus dem sowjetischen Marxismus
längenismus stammen es ist daher nicht
überraschend dass die Beziehungen zur
verwit-union so eng waren das erklärt
zum großen Teil warum die USA den
Vietnamkrieg so ernst Damen eine
Konflikt indem die nordvietnamesischen
Truppen von der Sowjetunion unterstützt
und gefördert worden und genau das
gleiche Gefahren 1979 als China als
Vergeltung für den Angriff Vietnams auf
das mörderische Regime der Roten Meer in
Kambodscha in das Land einmarschierte
egal ob die Invasion von den Amerikanern
oder die Chinesen ausgehen die
Sowjetunion der teuerste Partner des
kommunistischen vietnames half dem Land
und zwar indem sie ein ganzes Arsenal an
Waffen schickte etwa Flugabwehrraketen
leicht der Maschinengewehre und das
berüchtigte AK 74 Sturmgewehr auch wenn
die Beziehungen zwischen den beiden
Ländern bereits sehr eng waren wurde die
Freundschaft von da an noch viel stärker
tatsächlich ist Russland auch heute noch
der größte waffenpartner der
vietnamesischen Armee russland hat sogar
bevorzugten Zugang zu einem der
wichtigsten vietnamesischen Stützpunkt
Bay aber passt jetzt gut auf denn das
ist noch lange nicht das Ende dieser
Veranstaltung
Vietnam waren nicht nur bei der
Beschaffung von Waffen auf die
Sowjetunion und das heutige Russland
angewiesen auch die wirtschaftlich
Zusammenarbeit war in dieser Zeit
entscheidend wollt ihr ein Beispiel nun
in den letzten Jahren hat Vietnam
versucht mit Hilfe vieler
multinationaler Unternehmen Öle im
Südchinesischen Meer zu fördern zum
Beispiel in Zusammenarbeit mit dem
spanischen Unternehmen soll der
Knackpunkt dabei es geht um Förderung in
umstrittenen Gewässern und natürlich
würde man schneller und viel leichter
als Öl herankommen wenn sich eine
russische Staatsunternehmen einmischen
und seinen Einfluss in Peking zur
Geltung bringen würde tja und rein
zufällig war das jetzt der erste Konzern
der diese Gelegenheit nutzte wohl es
später seinen gesamten Anteil an
sarupation ein anderes staatliches
russisches Energieunternehmen verkaufte
aber an dieser Stelle habe ich eine
kleine Frage an euch was glaubt ihr wie
sich wird Namen für Russland gefallen
revanchiert nun Nachrichten wie die
folgende sind ein ziemlich guter Hinweis
Vietnam und Thailand enthalten sich bei
der unabstimmung zur Verurteilung der
russischen Annexion der Ukraine ganz
genau Vietnam ist eines der wenigen am
Ende der Welt das den russischen
Einmarsch in die Ukraine nicht
verurteilt hat
und das ergibt Sinn ohne die ständige
Unterstützung des Sowjetunion in der
Vergangenheit und des heutigen Russlands
wäre Vietnam wahrscheinlich nicht das
was es heute ist das ganze ist dann
allerdings doch noch etwas komplizierter
als das schließlich war auch die Ukraine
damals ein Teil der Sowjetunion und
daher besteht auch eine gewisse
Tradition der Beziehungen neu und GF das
liegt vor allem daran dass es in der
Ukraine viele Vietnamesen gibt und dass
die Ukraine auch eine der
Hauptlieferanten militärischer
Ausrüstung für Vietnam ist die Ukraine
hat eine sehr wichtige Rolle dabei
gespielt wird Namen bei der Aufrüstung
und Modernisierung seines Militärs zu
unterstützen
Außenministerium militärische Ausrüstung
Vietnams wird für Wartungsarbeiten in
die Ukraine geschickt die Aktivität
findet im Rahmen der etablierten
verteidigungskooperation zwischen
Vietnam und der Ukraine statt tja wie
ihr seht in Vietnam ist alles ein wenig
kompliziert und die Vietnamesen sind
sich vollkommen bewusst darüber dass sie
deswegen nicht alles auf eine Karte
setzen dürfen wenn sie überleben wollen
denn falls China wirklich mal die
Initiative ergreifen sollte und die
vietnamesische Regierung bestrafen oder
auswechseln oder gar in das Land
einmarschieren und ist in einem
Satellitenstadt verwandeln wollte
während die Russen natürlich keine echte
Hilfe angesichts der neuen Fähigkeiten
der chinesischen Armee und der
offensichtlichen Schwächen Russlands
wäre es für Moskau heute sehr schwierig
wenn ich sogar unmöglich ihnen
substanziell zu helfen und macht euch
keinerlei Illusion das ist den
Entscheidungsträgern in Hanoi glasklar
sie haben eine Supermarkt vor ihrer
Haustür eine Macht die zunehmend
expansionistisch und imperialistisch ist
und mit der sie sich nicht besonders gut
verstehen und sie wollen auf keinen Fall
zu ihrem Satellit enstadt werden
und deswegen hat um einen möglichen
Zusammenstoß zu vermeiden hat neu in den
letzten Jahren vieles versucht um die
Beziehung zu Peking zu glätten und dies
ist nicht nur eine territoriale oder
militärische Frage zu Vergleich fast 40%
aller vietnamesischen Importe kommen aus
China darunter Mikrochips Mobiltelefone
und jede Menge anderer Elektronik kurz
gesagt praktisch alles was das Land für
seine technologische Entwicklung braucht
das erklärt zum Beispiel auch warum
beide Länder in diesem Jahrhundert
Dutzende von militärischen Kooperation
Übungen durchgeführt haben
27 juli 2023 Vietnam und China
verstärkten Zusammenarbeit im
Verteidigungsbereich der
stellvertretende Verteidigungsminister
generell
bekräftigte dass die vietnamesische
Partei die Regierung und das
Verteidigungsministerium der umfassenden
strategischen Kooperationspartnerschaft
zwischen Vietnam und China stets große
Bedeutung bei Messen und fühlte hinzu
dass Sie umfassende Zusammenarbeit
zwischen den beiden Parteien und den
beiden Ländern ein voraussetzung für die
Förderung der bilateralen
verteidigungsbeziehung in verschiedenen
Bereichen ist ganz im Sinne der
gemeinsamen erklärungsförderung und
Vertiefung umfassende strategischen
Kooperationspartnerschaft zwischen
Vietnam und China die anlässlich des
offiziellen Besuchs von Partei
Generalsekretär new and Futon zum 21
oktober bis 1 November in China
abgegeben wurde ein ganz schön langer
Satz den die staatsopagandisten in Hanau
da zusammengeschustert haben nicht wahr
fast könnte man meinen sie hätten es
bitte nötig derartige diplomatische
ersatzmonster aufzufahren um hinter
ihnen zu verbergen wie es um die
Beziehungen zwischen beiden Ländern
wirklich steht hierzu muss man wissen
bisher basierte die Außenpolitik
Vietnams auf der Philosophie der drei
nein das bedeutet keine ausländischen
Militärbasen in Vietnam zuzulassen nicht
teil von militären müssen zu sein und
kein Land in seinem Kampf gegen eine
anderes zu unterstützen all das um China
nicht zu verärgern aber was wenn diese
Strategie eine Fehler war trotzdem drei
nein haben die Spannungen mit China in
süditalienischen mehr in den letzten
zehn Jahren ja zugenommen und die
Situation in der Region ist nicht mehr
auf die leichte Schulter zu nehmen
Vietnam gerät zunehmend ins Schwitzen
und zwischen wenn die Stühle Indien
schenkt Vietnam ein ausgemustertes
Kriegsschiff und nimmt China in die
Zange abgesehen von der Konfrontation
mit China unter dem Aspekt der aseern
Zentralität im indopazifischen Raum wird
erwartet dass dieser Schritt die
südostasiatischen Märkte für die
indische Rüstungsindustrie öffnen wird
hanoi ist klar es will und kann nicht
mehr der Spielball der Großmächte sein
es will sein Schicksal selbst in die
Hand nehmen und es glaubt auch es hätte
einen geeigneten Weg gefunden dieses
große Ziel zu erreichen wollt ihr wissen
wie dieser Weg aussieht dann aufgepasst
[Musik]
die Vergangenheit hinter sich lassen
wie wir euch bereits erzählt haben hat
Vietnam ab 1986 eine Reihe
marktwirtschaftliche Reformen
eingeleitet zu Beginn beschränkten sich
diese Reformen auf den Agrarsektor und
griffen später auch auf die übrigen
Wirtschaftssektoren über eine der
wichtigsten Maßnahmen war die
Industrialisierung des Landes um jeden
Preis um erfolgreich zu sein musste das
Land Investoren aus dem Rest der Welt um
Verben und Ansehen und glaubt mir sie
haben diese Aufgabe verdammt ernst
genommen fakt ist vietnam hat sich von
einem Krieg zerstörten kommunistischen
Staat zu einer sich schnell entwickelten
faktischen Marktwirtschaft gewandelt der
Schlüssel dazu war das neue
Reformprogramm in den 80er Jahren dass
die vietnamesische Wirtschaft für Handel
und ausländische Investitionen öffnete
infolgedessen ist Vietnam zu einem
wahren Fertigungszentrum geworden wobei
Unternehmen aus dem Konsumsektor wie zum
Beispiel Nike alles auch
Technologieunternehmen die Samsung
Google und Apple ihre Produktion von
China nach Vietnam verlagern die
katastrophale Null Covic Politik Pekings
und auch diese und stetig wachsende
politische Unsicherheit in roten Riesen
wir haben diesen Trend beschleunigt da
Unternehmen erkannt haben dass eine zu
große Abhängigkeit von China ein
erhebliches Risiko darstellt sie sind
bestrebt ihre Lieferketten zu
diversifizieren und Vietnam hat sich
dabei als der ideale Partner erwiesen
Herr neues im Vergleich zu Peking viel
effektivere Reaktion auf die Pandemie
und der stabile Geschäftsumfeld mit viel
höherer Rechtssicherheit machen es zu
einer sehr attraktiven Alternative
Analyse Investoren die China verlassen
investieren in andere Schwellenländer
Jeffrey jenniferkic ci der Singapurer
Staatsform die als sie sagte dass er
sein Kapital schrittweise in Sektoren
und Ländern verlagert hat die von den
Verschiebungen in der globalen
Lieferkette profitieren und dass das
meiste davon grundsätzlich aus China in
Länder wie Mexiko Indien indonesien und
Vietnam geflossen ist über die Flucht
der Unternehmen aus China haben wir auf
unserem schwesterkanal visual economic
ein eigenes Video gedreht und hier auch
Politik auch schon über Mexiko als das
neue China die neue Fabrik für die
US-Wirtschaft und wer ist auch der mit
Abstand größte Kunde Vietnams genau die
US Open das ist nicht überraschend die
Beziehungen mit der nordamerikanischen
Supermacht haben sich in den letzten
Jahren stark verbessern
[Musik]
die Zeiten von Krieg und Misstrauen sind
vorbei 1995 stellten die beiden Länder
offizielle ihre diplomatischen
Beziehungen wieder her 2000 und das
zeichneten sie ein bilaterales
Handelsabkommen 2007 trat Vietnam mit
ausdrücklicher Unterstützung Washingtons
der Welthandelsorganisation bei und 2016
hoben die Vereinigten Staaten das Waffen
im Vietnam vollständig auf sie
ermöglichten damit also auch eine enge
Zusammenarbeit in Sicherheit und
Verteidigungsfragen wir konnten bilder
wie diese erleben
seitdem haben die beiden Länder sogar
zahlreiche gemeinsame Militärübungen
durchgeführt und arbeiten Routine mäßig
im Bereich der maritimen Sicherheit und
der Freiheit der Schifffahrt im
indopazifischen Raum zusammen aber
nachdem wir euch ja vorhin erzählt haben
dass Vietnam eigentlich versucht so gut
wie möglich mit China auszukommen wie
erklärt sich der plötzliche Wunsch eine
so gute Beziehung zu seinem historischen
Erzfeind und Chinas derzeitigen
herzustellen
nun abgesehen von wirtschaftlichen
Fragen ist die Wahrheit eben dass man in
Hanoi Peking überhaupt nicht über den
Weg traut tatsächlich erreichten die
Spannungen zwischen den beiden Ländern
2014 ein extremes Niveau als China eine
halbtaugfähige Ölplattform in das
vietnamesische Meeresgebiet brachte um
dort Öl zu suchen und zu fördern und
nicht nur das der Bau künstliche Inseln
um die Bradley und parallel-inseln die
Vietnam für sich beansprucht hat die
Spannungen in der Region wachsen lassen
vor allem wegen dem militärischen
Ausrüstung die China auf diesen Insel
installiert ja ganz genau china baut
einfach künstliche Militärbasen in den
vietnamesischen Gewässern und deshalb
scheint man in Hannover jetzt zu
verstehen dass weder Moskau noch Peking
die sich ersten Partner sind sondern
dass man stattdessen auf die Vereinigten
Staaten und ihre Verbündeten in der
Region setzen muss natürlich hat
Washington diese Verschiebung als
Glücksfall erkannt als einen weiteren
potenziellen Partner der sich in die
bereits lange Liste der Länder Einheit
die China gegenüber verärgert oder
misstrauisch sind und das erklär t in
gewisser Weise auch Nachrichten wie
diese 29 März 2018 die Vereinigten
Staaten liefern 6 mittelshark patroute
am Vietnam aus
20 November 2019 USA Schinken Vietnam
ein Schiff zu Verstärkung der Patienten
im umstrittenen Süd chinesischen Meer
17 dezember 2022 Analyse Vietnam
schaltet beim Waffenhandel einen Gang
zurück und lockert die Beziehungen zu
Russland tja anstatt russische Waffen zu
kaufen strömen jetzt amerikanisches
südkoreanische und israelische Waffen
nach Vietnam bedeutet das aber nun das
Vietnam seine drei nein Philosophie
ändern und sich komplett in die Arme von
Uncle Cent werfen wird nun definitiv
nicht
vietnam ist ein durchaus erstaunlicher
Fall von einem Land das im Moment mit
Peking Moskau und Washington
gleichzeitig Auskommen zu wollen scheint
aber dieses Dreieck wird wohl niemand
ewig ausbalancieren können und hinzu
kommt noch die liebäugelei mit Pekings
Erz Rivalen neu.de also macht kein
Fehler Vietnam ist immer noch eine
kommunistische Diktatur westliche
politische und demokratische Werte sind
nicht Teil der Kommunistischen Partei
und das schenkt das Vertrauen der
Vereinigten Staaten in Vietnam 1 in
Washington weiß man das Vietnam keine
klassischer Verbündeter ist sondern nur
darauf bedacht seine eigenen Interessen
zu schützen es ist beispielsweise kaum
zu erwarten dass Vietnam an der Seite
der Vereinigten Staaten Taiwan zu Hilfe
ein würde um ein Angriff Chinas zu
verhindern es will nicht mehr der
Spielball von Großmächten sein und das
ist dem lange geschundenen Land nicht
abzusprechen Vietnam ist mittlerweile in
der Lage zu einer aufstrebenden
Wirtschafts- und politischen groß macht
den Asien zu werden während es seine
fertigungsbasis und Partnerschaften mit
den USA und anderen Ländern ausbaut um
China auszubalancieren seine Entwicklung
vom Kriegsopfer zum kapitalistischen
Erfolgsmodell kann dabei als Vorbild für
sich entwickelnde Volkswirtschaften
dienen doch mit wachsender Macht wächst
auch die Verantwortung und wenn wir in
die Geschichte blicken erkennen wir
schnell das es nicht in der Natur der
Vietnamesen liegt verantwortungslos zu
handeln von ihrem mutigen Kampf gegen
die verbrecherischen Roten Meer und den
Widerstandes übermächtigen Peking haben
wir euch ja vorhin schon erzählt also
vielleicht besinnen sie sich ja auch
diesmal nachdem sie ihre Balance ihre
Mitte und ihre Stärke gefunden haben
darauf dass sie doch eine wesentlich
vernünftigere und verantwortungsvollere
Nation sind als China und vielleicht
helfen sie am Ende doch noch dem anderen
David Südostasiens Taiwan es würde sich
um ein weiteres Puzzleteil in großen
geopolitischen Spiel dieses Jahrhundert
handelt der Verhinderung eines durch
Peking auslösten Krieges um vor Moser
aber dass meine Lieben Zuschauer ist
schon wieder ein Thema für weitere
Videos vergesst also wie gesagt nicht
das Abo unbedingt mit Glöckchen um
keines davon zu verpassen und bis dahin
sind die Fragen an Euch gerichtet wenn
ihr vie Wert auf welche Seite würdet ihr
euch Stellen Moskau Peking oder
Washington würdet ihr Taiwan helfen wenn
es notwendig wäre und ihr die Macht dazu
hättet und ist euch eigentlich im Barbie
movie die anstößige Karte des
Südchinesischen Meeres aufgefallen wie
immer sind wir auf eure Diskussion zu
diesem Thema schon mächtig gespannt ich
hoffe dass euch dieses Video gefallen
hat und die vielleicht auch was dabei
gelernt habt falls ja gibt es bitte ein
Like heißt mit euren Freunden und
diskutiert das auch mit ihnen natürlich
freuen wir uns auch jederzeit über eine
Spende von euch dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen den Link dazu findet ihr
in der Beschreibung oder dem Video
mach's gut und bis bald
[Musik]